yeah everyone i made it i actually have an hour and 10
minutes so i've technically made it okay let me enable okay
um all right i i enable all right live there we go you guys
got that all right all right okay this is a bit rough
because i might oh man this is pretty rough i can't even
tweet that i'm live that's the worst part i can't even tweet
out that i'm live because Twitter is down.
Twitter is down right now.
I can't even tweet out that I'm alive.
Yeah, nothing is loading for me.
Yeah, nothing.
Oh, my Twitter's back.
Twitter's back.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right, here we go.
All right, all right, all right.
Live now because live on Twitter.
now because I forgot B-C-A-U-S because I forgot that I took
a couple of Twitch sponsor stuff sponsor stuff again on that
sponsorship tab thing and the deadline and the deadline is
one hour
It's keep happening, it keep happening.
All right, there you go.
There you go.
All right, all right, all right.
We made it.
All right.
So, we're going to start.
We're going to start it now.
At least you're honest about it.
All right, all right.
Let's are guys ready?
Are you guys ready?
I have a couple.
I have to Are you guys ready, you guys?
Okay, okay.
All right.
Thank you all for coming to my Twitch stream.
That's my professional streamer.
Can't swear today.
Can't swear.
Okay, maybe I can on the other one, but not this one.
Anyway, are you guys ready?
All right, we're going to start now.
All right.
All right, let's watch this movie trailer.
Let's go.
Wait, where's the?
Where did I?
Let's watch this.
Are you all ready?
All right, we're ready.
In my upcoming film, Shelter.
I'm going to go.
never watched this one i play michael mason a man hiding
from his past oh my god that's jason stadham must come out
of the shadows wait that is worth standing ground for to
have a chance i could be jason stadham and fortnite now it's
your turn to take on the threats to check what is important
gain the experience of jason my goat and ultimately yes that
guy from fast and furious the storm is coming wait you saw
this movie what do you rate it you can Jason Statham in
Fortnite.
All right, so this is a film starring Jason Statham.
It's only in theaters January 3rd.
Wait, it's in theaters now!
Guys, you can actually check out the movie right now.
It is an action-packed film starring Jason Statham, one of
Jason Statham's most layered performances yet.
Her safety, his mission, unshackled.
This is the calm before the storm.
It's not just a creative map, it's a full roguelike.
That means every time we die, we keep our gold, hit the
upgrade hub, and come back stronger than ever.
It's got that just one more run energy, and I know you guys
love it.
If you're a fan of Jason Saddam, you have to see it.
This map is tied to his new movie, Shelter.
We're basically playing alongside him as an Elite M16
assassin.
We even get to team up with this character, Michael Mason,
for the final boss fight.
Look at this skill tree.
We can unlock weapon upgrades, better supplies, and even get
help from Jack the Dog for mid-run, oh my, mid-run buffs.
Oh my god, they got a dog in this movie.
Help me decide what to spec into first.
Do we go full glass cannon or build for survival so we can
actually reach the lighthouse?
atmosphere in this UEFN map is insane.
They recreated that moody Scottish island vibe from the
movie perfectly.
It feels less like a minigame and more like a standalone
action game in sight inside Fortnite.
This is, by the way, just to be clear, this is also in
support of the movie.
And Shelter is in theaters right now.
Yeah, and Fortnite, they brought the basically they brought
the films the film stuff to life so in fortnite so you can
play as jason jason statum um and this is a new side of
jason that we haven't seen before remember it's in theaters
on january 30th right now yay oh my god it's jason statum
and then that's your name
Thank you.
All right.
So, yeah, it's me.
Yep.
I made it.
I mean, it's not Fortnite right now.
I mean, I feel like I could, I feel like I should, let's try
it out.
I'm actually curious.
What is this gameplay like?
Let me try.
Yeah, let's actually try out this game mode.
I might as well have, uh, we have an hour of this.
All right.
me a sec i am going to i am going to boot it up right now i
actually really want to know what this game mode is like
yeah it's time to play it wait you're right i forgot oh no
it's updating all right guys we're updating right now mike
thank you for gifting a tier one sub to rambon thank you
thank you um yeah see guys i'm part i'm a consumer just like
you i'm yeah i'm just like you guys i'm the people but i
need to wait i need to wait for the update i don't know what
i can say or can't say i'm trying to be careful like i don't
know what i can say or can't say so i'm like the safest
option is to just boot up fortnite right now i just
downloaded fortnite what code do i use you can use jockey
bird at fortnite to get well nothing but um it does support
me and i think that's pretty cool uh you don't get anything
by using my code but it's pretty cool to support your
favorite streamer if it i don't know I don't know.
I feel like that's pretty neat.
Isn't that neat?
Nothing.
I love nothing.
There we go.
That's my favorite consumer.
That's right.
Consume this.
That's the best part.
Exactly.
You know it.
We all know it.
just keep consuming all right wait let me double check
something all right I did the streamer read thing correctly
yeah let's see I gotta make sure everything is fine all
right we'll do oh wait I can't mention anything else I can't
make sure I don't accidentally mention anything make sure i
don't mention any competitors all right all right here we go
that's why i need to play it safe guys i paid you and i get
to consume nothing sign me no no you consume the stuff i
tell you to consume no no no no no no no here you consume
what i tell you to consume and
wait what is this whoa wait i got some wait what else is i
got sent something anyway we're chilling today oh it's this
jesus christ that's oh you guys don't hear it
you guys don't hear it but there's like something i have to
check right now i i have to check a video right now real
quick oh okay okay i gotta let me give my um okay i need to
make sure i don't spoil it
wepper thank you for the five gift themselves thank you
thank you
all right it's anniversary related sorry guys it's at a it's
anniversary related that's why i'm quiet because i don't
want to spoil anything um
all right there you go there you go
all right all right let's do i let's boot up fortnite let's
go let's check this out let's go consume like a good
consumer we are let's go okay let me double check what i
never all right that's fine how am i still awake pure
adrenaline right now i told you i've hit my second win done
it I have truly hit my second win ah fortnight fortnight oh
why is fortnight there we go I also have to all right I also
gotta buy new skins too they have released a ton of new
skins all right let's let's check out the shop for today.
Yay!
Okay, I don't like him, but I like Mordecai and Rigby look
great, though.
I think this is, oh my god, the baby ducks.
Oh my god, wait, the baby ducks.
What's the offer?
I like this.
I think this is great.
Oh!
I like this.
And the baby ducks.
The baby ducks, that's gonna beat me.
up oh but okay so sabrina carpenter is back doja cat i
forgot doja cat was it wait doja cat is in here
what's this bad guy oh shit wait bad guy's pretty goes hard
though oh my that's not the ice king i know Oh, I have it.
I consumed so much.
I didn't even realize I have it already.
I was ready to buy it again.
I was so ready to buy it again.
I was like, oh my God, I gotta get this.
It's like people who subscribe to mystery boxes, you know?
They're like, that's how they get you.
Like those loot boxes slash mystery boxes, that's how they
get you.
You subscribe it once.
It's like a gym membership.
You just never cancel it.
You're in too deep.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
I can buy it cheaper than a real car.
You're like, yeah, I have a Ford F-150.
Oh, my God.
There's the Ford Mustang.
Wait.
Was it there Ed?
Where's Ed?
Wait, what's this?
It's like a real one, but more affordable.
Okay.
All right.
What is this?
Nothing but a cheat thing.
Look at him go.
Oh my god.
Go Ice King.
This is so lower accurate.
That is actually lower accurate Ice King.
Oh my god.
He's he's busting it out.
He really.
Oh, I forgot to swap.
I forgot to swap the Fortnite.
i'm on fortnite now all right what's this
what about this oh my god he's surfing he's surfing right
now swag i'm safe oh my there it is okay i have to get wait
it's leaving today oh shit okay give me a sec okay i'm just
okay someone actually was like you should fight you should
just commit
I gotta stop buying it one by one and they were right
they're like why do you keep buying like mini I keep
thinking it'll be over you know you know how like you keep
thinking like this is it this is the last time I purchased I
purchased something on the shop but then jokes on me it's
never the last time oh my god I almost forgot to use the
creator code here you go guys remember I
Oh my god, it's leaving today.
I gotta be Ed.
I love how the line art also goes so well for it.
Alright.
Don't forget to use.
Okay, I like that.
I like that I have Plank too.
And I have a Jawbreaker.
Alright.
Nice.
I always feel like this is the last time I'll this is the
last time I'll buy I'll, this is the last time I'll buy
something in the Fortnite shop.
But it was, it's never the last time.
I finally accepted it, guys.
I finally accepted that I'm in too deep.
I'm in too deep.
Wait, is there Naruto Run here?
Oh my god, wait, is that the, what is this?
Is that where I get to fly?
Oh, is that the, the...
Oh, wait, where's the Naruto Run?
They didn't have the Naruto Run.
What's the point?
What about this?
Who else is leaving bad already?
What about the office?
Wait, is the office gone already?
What?
It's only in the shop where like, are you fucking getting
me?
The office is already gone?
I was gonna buy...
I was gonna buy Dwight.
I can't believe it.
It literally was there for...
It left yesterday.
it down it's okay i i still have regular show i want it to
be dwight yeah they knew they knew man they figured out the
system they figured it out all right let's buy
i want i want like i want this oh
that was such a short event god that fomo hit deep though
That FOMO truly did hit hard.
I actually got FOMOed so hard.
All right, let's...
Okay, what was it?
What was the...
It was shelter.
All right, let's find this.
Shelter.
All right, here we go.
Oh, my God.
It's a rogue, like, up to four players.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
No, wait.
Select.
Oh, my God, guys.
All right, let's get four players in here.
Wait, public?
Is there no public?
private room.
Wait, I can't have a private room here.
Oh, private.
There we go.
How do I make...
Oh, wait.
I can't at all.
Alright, let's do public then.
I can't have a... There's no custom key for this one.
I think this one doesn't have a custom key.
Like, I'm going to try it.
Um...
Wait, what the fuck?
Where's the custom key for this?
Did they change how this works?
What the fuck is my custom key?
Oh, there it is.
Okay, maybe it does work.
Am I...
Oh, I'm stupid.
I am.
I was like, am I just stupid?
And the answer is always yes.
All right, shelter.
All right, let's try this again.
Oh, there it is.
All right, custom key is Jokey Bird.
Just like my creator code.
I'm just trying to, like, get you guys, guys.
Custom key...
It's Doki Bird.
I'm trying to, like, get you guys more used to putting my
code in Fortnite.
You know, just so you're more used to...
Yeah, it's all lowercase Fortnite.
So you guys know how to use my code.
Yeah, getting used to writing Doki Bird.
I need two more players.
Two more players.
I'm conditioning you guys.
I what server east or west coast or central it's like a
little game you know a game within the game a little mystery
it's this it's time to find out which one is which all right
I think it was like four players right all right we'll now
have to download give me a sec truly a mystery eating dinner
yet i'm so hungry but it's okay we gotta get this done we
gotta get we gotta check this out is that ed yeah it's in
fortnite now i guess right congratulations you win a prize
you get to play shelter with me that's in feeders right now
by the way shelter is oh my god tattooed amikyu rigby and
the chicken from family guy we don't have much time just use
up there let me know it sounds good it truly is the collab
of all time this is our Avengers oh my god did you guys hear
that we got clear the room upgrade weapon shop rest area
chill earn passive cash okay but how do we this is my target
audience
i truly am a 13 year old kid in game in mentally mentally
mentally all right how do we do this Select.
I would like this pistol.
Alright, guys, come on.
Get over here.
We gotta go.
Come on.
Get over here.
Get your upgrades in.
We gotta move as a team.
Alright.
Let's go.
How does this work?
Enemy.
Alright.
Rigby!
How did you party guy?
How did you die already?
oh my god all right search the room for hidden words you can
find all right mason's dog is here to help pet him it'll
bring you oh where's the dog they said yeah there's the dog
remember we gotta find the dog the dog is here wait there's
a chest that it oh i got cash all right where's the dog Oh,
there he is!
You can pet the dog!
Did you just... Oh my no.
Okay, I was gonna say... Oh, each item you get... Okay,
someone's gotta heal Rigby but like Mordecai, but it's not
gonna be me.
There's coconut.
What the heck does a coconut do?
Damage 24?
24 is higher than...
Actually, I don't know.
Alright, someone heal him.
Someone should heal him.
Someone should really Yeah, well, I found this Alright,
let's go Let's go to the next room
Oh shit I got my money My cash money Huh Okay, guys, don't
look Don't look Don't look Okay guys i was playing there you
go see there you go did you see that though don't look guys
don't look oh he healed oh we got poked the dog yeah wait
what's this slap juice what is the heck is slap juice all
right let me eat this real quick i'm yum yum yum yum yum yum
Alright, are y'all ready?
Oh my god.
Let's go.
Go, Ed.
Go.
Yeah!
Alright, guys, come on!
Chicken for Family Guy and Mordecai.
We gotta do this!
Wait.
Hasune Miku is a gamer.
Guys, oh my god.
Hasune Miku is gaming right now.
I have to hit like actual headshots.
I feel like my sense is weird.
It ain't right.
It ain't right right now.
I pet the dog.
What did she...
What did the dog get me?
Oh, hey!
New gun!
Yay!
Wait, there's money.
I'm gonna check my sense real quick.
Wait, what?
Wait, is Mordecai dying again?
Mordecai, what are you doing?
Oh, we can't help you.
We can only watch.
That's why you got solo this yourself.
That's on you.
You thought you can get carried?
Let me double check my sense real quick.
Oh my god, unlimited.
Wait, did it actually?
Oh my god, I think somebody died.
Wait, motion blur off.
Where's my sense?
Where is it?
where's my sense here which tab is it what the heck guys I
gotta figure out my sense real quick guys I sit beside it
where's my sense oh there we go is this defa or is this is
this normal save is that defa is mortikai still over there
oh my god mortikai oh wait what's he doing oh hey mason's
armory wait i'm broke i don't have that much money
what the heck why does mason want so much money from me oh
wait i'll get uh i don't want this is he here yet let's
watch mordecai all right someone convert my rival sense guys
right now it's 1.89 800 dpi converted to fortnite for me
all right don't worry we're don't worry we'll cheer you on
Don't worry, Mordecai!
You got this!
He did it!
Let's go!
Oh, wait.
That's an extra dog.
All right, let's go.
Let's move on.
All right, someone...
Oh, shit!
Oh, my God.
I have inflicted...
Why is it all...
Fucking pistols.
Oh!
No!
Protect me!
Body block, body block, body block.
Alright.
Don't worry.
Someone convert my thing.
Okay.
You just needed to hit me once and he didn't do it.
There we go.
Look at that.
I did my job.
There you go.
Nice.
I did it.
Alright.
Did anyone convert my sense?
Oh, what?
Alright, pet the dog.
Okay, I should like...
Oh, I should like that gun.
Give me that.
Yeah, but I meant like...
Say it's 5.94.
Okay, let me check that real quick.
5.94.
Okay.
Are you serious?
It...
Okay.
5.9?
Alright, 5.9.
Alright.
Oh my god, now I don't.
Okay, 5.9.
All right, we good.
Let's go.
Let's go, guys.
Move, move, move.
Okay, 5.9.
All right.
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god, he's missing.
That's good.
I'm covering you.
Suppressing fire.
Wait, where is he?
Oh, there he is.
There, nice.
God damn it, Alan.
Come on.
Come on, bro.
We can't cure.
you all day 5.6 close enough 5.6 5.9 that's close enough
wait does he took my item oh i should eat the fish okay i
should not be eating the fish it does nothing i actually
don't know what the fish does
does it tell me what it does zero point fish hello what does
it do All right, I'll grab this.
All right, let's go.
Move, move, move.
Come on.
Come on, guys.
Gas, gas, gas.
Oh, it's super jump.
Oh, so it's used this.
Oh, my God.
There's so much HP.
What the fuck?
I'm drinking my juice.
My sloppy juice.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Wait, they're gaming now.
Wait, these guys are gaming.
I got reload in front of him.
Watch this.
Oh, they're dead.
Never mind.
Did you watch, though?
Nice.
We did it.
Oh my god, there's still one more.
Oh my god, there's so many.
Pet the dog.
I got more slappy juice, whatever the fuck that is.
Oh, I forgot to select my upgrades.
I almost forgot about upgrades.
Alright, banana.
Wait, no!
Are you serious?
I didn't select upgrades for, like, three rounds.
Alright, I got bananas, though.
Alright, let's go.
Wait, did we... Someone die?
God damn it, Alan.
Alan, get over here.
Alan, get over here, Alan.
Come on!
Oh, shit.
Wherever did I go?
More banana More banana
Alright guys We gotta wait for Alan He's gotta solo this
himself We're watching you We're watching you right now
We'll cheer you on from here
What the fuck What the I'm getting him styling on his body
how did you die oh he tried to rock and launch he rocked and
launched himself one love for this is my darling honey
Don't worry, he's got...
He's almost there.
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba, all I want for
Christmas is you.
Oh, yeah, bear.
All I want to not bring.
All right, what else?
Oh, wait, what else do I have?
I don't want to...
all for christmas oh no no no no no i have this let's go
yeah we're jelly fishing now bump bump
oh my god he's almost there he's almost there he's gonna
make it why are you helping him he's gotta learn himself Oh,
he died.
Okay.
He died.
You gotta help him, I guess.
Oh,
I can't shoot it.
There's a barrier.
I refuse to help.
He's gotta learn.
Wait, he's dead.
Time to restart, Alan.
Wait.
Create him.
Oh, shit, nice.
Yay, free item.
Twin hammer shot.
Wait, that's like OP as hell.
Goink.
Mine now.
Yay.
Where is he?
Oh, he has to start from one.
Guys, I think we might have to move.
Oh, hey, nice.
Guys, I think we might have to replace Alan.
He's a little bit of a dead weight right now.
Surprisingly, I thought it'd be Mordecai.
Wait, he's almost there.
He's making it.
Wait, Alan.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh.
this area.
Oh, I have.
It's okay, Morphus.
It's okay.
You're not last.
We have a new target.
All right, but also, Mordecai, you did die in the first
room, though.
You did die in the first room.
Yeah, they give it 100 videos.
Thank you, thank you.
This is the plot of the movie.
Oh, he's making it.
He's making it.
Come on, Alan.
You're almost there.
Don't worry, I'll show you.
This is more accurate.
Drop it like it's hot.
Alan,
you're almost there, Alan!
We're helping!
We're helping, Alan!
We're giving you a show!
All right, let's go.
Let's move on.
Next room.
We got this.
Come on, let's go.
All right, now that we're all here, room clear.
All right, let's go to the next room.
Yeah, I'm loon-alting.
I'm loon-alting right now.
Oh, enemies appearing.
Oh, oh.
Are they all in that tunnel?
Oh, my God.
Okay, that's okay.
I'm suppressing fire.
There you go.
Oh my god.
Wait, can I shoot through here?
I can't.
Oh my god.
We actually can't shoot from this.
Okay, who shot me?
Okay, who was it?
Who was it?
Let me eat my bananas real quick.
The where?
I'm shooting arrows.
all right who fell oh no not soon amiku don't worry they
can't they can't go through
watch oh wait i don't think don't worry i got my got my
sloppy juice whatever that is wait he has shotguns too wait
that's cheating He's sliding in!
Wait, he's one!
He's one!
Someone go in!
Nice.
What the...
Okay, these guys are, like, jacked up.
Like, they have more HP than 10 people.
One more.
Where's the last guy?
Wait, where's the last guy?
He's hiding.
Where did he go?
Oh, there he is.
The AI stopped working.
All right, we gotta get the shield potion.
Like, I'm messed up right now.
I'm actually messed up.
All right, get that money.
Oh, pet the dog.
Wait, that was mine.
Wait.
Excuse me.
Um.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
That was mine.
All right, are we all ready?
Next room?
What is this?
Oh, wait, is that beam?
Wait, how much damage can I do for this?
Do I have to charge it all the way up?
Okay, that's a little mess.
All right, let's go.
That's a little messed up.
Oh, no, not another corridor.
Oh, no.
All right, guys, there is...
Maybe we can get him to come out.
Oh, there's like a charge up.
I don't know if I like that.
Alright, don't worry.
I got my shotguns in.
But don't worry, I got high ground.
Okay, okay, they're...
They're covering high ground!
Alright, alright.
It's okay.
Oh my god, boycott's got this!
There we go.
Slow and steady, guys.
Alright, we've secured high ground.
Oh my god, he's team bagging!
all right nice don't worry i've secured high ground
there you go it's okay the ai doesn't know
don't worry i got this high ground secured oh my god guys
why did you lock her back in wait there's a lady here
because she isn't aware she doesn't know
Is that we have two more
Oh her Oh I got this I got this guys I'm helping She just
needs to stop moving Damn guys It's hard to aim when they
are moving Who would have thought?
Shield mushroom I actually need that Oh my shield mushroom
I'm gonna get rid of the charge rifle thing I don't think
that that one's good Okay I actually need shields though
all right nice all right pet the dog oh hey
wait what what what did he drop like what what did he even
drop oh real gun is that for me
okay that was literally like what i got from before all
right let's go oh nice we did it oh we oh my god we shot the
dog so we could we could grab the items.
All right.
Okay, it's fine.
I'm helping.
All right, nice.
Okay, I'm just going to use this.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
See, they can't aim.
Wait, this is so easy.
Okay, oh, more to cut.
That's awkward.
Just keep crawling.
We're gonna save you.
Alright.
I got you.
Don't worry.
Hatsune Miku is carrying right now.
Watch this.
Boom!
Oh.
The bat.
That's expected.
The backshot.
Bam!
Easy.
And then we pet the dog.
Oh, hey, Ness.
Shoot.
Oh, God.
I'm sorry.
Wait, how did I do it last time?
Wait, guys, how did we do this?
How did we move him?
Oh, oh,
that's...
No, I deserved that.
I really did.
We gotta move the dog!
Yes!
Where should the dog go?
Oh, he's over.
We did it.
We moved the dog.
We did it, guys.
guys we moved the dog very safely okay how much do i have i
still i'm so broke i'm so broke right now wait i didn't get
the money though i hear you i'm ready 200 really i did so
much there and i only get 200 buckaroons all right are you
guys ready are you guys already all right let's go how many
Are in here anyway?
I mean, it is a road leg.
Oh, no.
The boss is coming.
Oh, it's an open area.
Oh, this is a lot harder when it's in the open.
Oh, God.
Oh, the rock is here.
It's okay.
We have our own rock.
Oh!
own rock there you go nice oh my i'm running out of shields
though oh wait oh my god wait he's throwing rocket launchers
oh it's okay it's okay i'm baiting him i'm baiting him don't
worry guys ed's got this i'm ledge peaking him
look at that i'm gaming i'm gaming right now i'm gaming so
hard Literally ledge peaking.
Alright.
Easy.
What's this?
We got a cutscene.
I'll need.
Just stay with me.
Oh my god.
We went in.
This is basically...
We're basically...
Alright, let's see.
Okay, we gotta grab that.
We're basically watching a movie right now.
I don't...
to there, take this mushroom.
I need this.
Alright, where's the dog?
Guys, where's the dog?
We gotta pet the dog.
Wait, where did our dog go?
Claim one.
To advance, you need one get.
Claim one revert.
Guys.
Guys, I accidentally guys.
I pet the dog Guys Guys
Increase the love What did we do?
It said claim a rebirth Alright we can't Okay we had to
Everyone
We are messed up a little.
I'm not upgrading these yet.
Oh, whoa.
What the heck?
Increase your cash income from several sources.
Oh!
Upgrade cash.
Chest RNG.
Yeah, get me that shit.
Lure rewards.
Let's go.
Oh, this is the rogue leg.
Okay.
Okay, I felt like I should have saved it.
Oh.
That's awkward.
Yeah, I think I quit.
I was like, wait a minute.
I should be saving up, right?
I was getting damage.
Oh, so that's the rogue-like glass cannon time.
I mean, I can grab this.
All right.
Oh, okay.
Here's the guns.
Where's the gun?
Oh, here we go.
Get the SMG.
Okay.
All right, we figured it out.
Chill and earn.
What's speedrun mode?
End speedrun?
Chill and earn equip VFX?
Oh, this is where...
All right, we gotta passively earn our income.
Yay, rewards!
Oh, it's like AFK and chill.
deal oh that earned our little passive income right now what
do I have I have
around the world around the world around the world around
the world around the All right, let's go.
Come on.
Let's go.
Let's go back.
All right, I'll grab Burst SMG.
Come on, guys.
We got this.
I want to know what the...
What was the other thing that they were doing?
Like the...
Because it was like claim a Reaper, so we had to die there.
No!
Guys.
I made a little oopsie.
Guys, I need to go back.
I made a little oopsie and got a little too excited.
Alright, now let's pet the dog.
Where's my reward?
There you go.
That was mine.
That was my...
Yeah, I was gonna say that was mine.
He took my stuff.
Alright, we got the big boy.
We got the big chest.
hug.
Ah, guys, are you guys ready?
Let's go.
Wait, I'm not ready, actually.
Alright, I'm ready.
Let's go.
We know how to do this now.
We game the system.
We're stronger.
We're so much stronger.
I went all in on damage and no HP.
Oh my god, everybody is body blocking me.
How the... How did I get all the damage?
Where's my...
I hate him.
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, move the dog.
Where is my...
Oh, it killed him.
Alright, that's moving.
Mine now.
Oh, alright.
I'm ready.
Alright, let's go.
Alright, I gotta grab that.
I gotta chug it.
Alright, let's go.
Boy, I gotta grab my upgrade.
Alright, let's go for real.
Alright.
oh my this recoil is insane i feel like okay they like they
like does this game mode they adjusted the recoil this gun
recoil is goddamn crazy what throw that fish down right now
all right whoops i keep forgetting that we're not supposed
to eat these oh banana Really?
That gun is crazy for the recoil.
I felt like I was actually spraying and preying there.
Oh my god, I can't.
Okay, the pistol is doo-doo.
Let me grab the shotgun.
Let me play actual Fortnite.
I forgot.
Everyone in Fortnite just uses the shotgun.
Alright.
money yeah the revolver is pretty ass not gonna lie what the
heck is this men missed oh wait that's for healing we have a
heal now pack belongs to another well oh i can't noink it
from him
oh yoink all right let's go gas gas we're a speed run this
Give me a sec.
Alright, if I knew...
Look, if I knew the AoE was that bad.
I didn't see how I was going to speedrun this, to be fair.
Yay, shoot.
Um...
Alright.
Get that shit out of the way from me.
Get that...
Get that shit away from me.
I don't...
I don't trust...
I don't trust that anymore.
Not now.
Alright.
We have five shields?
Oh my god, I just noticed.
Oh man, this will... this area.
oh my god i gotta spray myself give me a sec i'm i'm cute
i'm hydrating real quick
yeah jesus okay i'm hydrating you know like those like misty
can miss cans i'm hydrating real quick guys i truly am a
glass i literally can't even peek i think everybody I'm
eating my banana.
I'm eating my banana real quick.
Where those cans where you spray yourself with those, like,
water mist things?
Okay, I only have one gun.
Oh, my God.
Get me out of here.
He's getting closer, guys.
He's getting close.
Oh, it's just okay.
I'm healing us.
Can't see me.
It's okay.
He can't see me.
Oh, my God.
I'm so scared.
We gotta get rid of him.
Oh my god.
The double shotgun!
Did someone upgrade the boss?
Why is he so strong?
You want some bananas, Ed boy?
All right, we did.
We pushed him.
Doggo.
Yeah, I'll grab that.
And then I gotta eat some fish.
all right i gotta grab this rush b rush b real quick oh god
damn i didn't mean to do that it's too late i committed to
it i'm so fucked up anyway all right let's go all right it's
time hog round we have to secure hog round By securing high
ground.
Oh, wait.
I forgot about this guy.
Oh, my God.
Morty, God, please.
I'm just hitting your fat ass.
Not that I'm judging, though.
Your ass is very lovely.
But you are in the way.
All right.
We're surrounding him.
Oh!
How the fuck
How did I just lose 90%?
Oh my gosh, I should have actually Invested in shields Oh my
god, I'm just shooting Please, please, I've hit Every rail
possible I'm actually just hitting The goddamn rails Alright
I still have one more health pack Yeah, it's Ed boy Are you
That's...
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
I still have one more health pack.
That's okay.
Everything is fine.
We did it.
Now I get to talk to my doggo.
Wait, what the?
Give me that med kit.
Give me that med kit, right?
Give me that.
That's unfortunate.
Alright, we're good to go.
go.
All right, guys, let's go.
We're all geared up.
All right.
I assume this is good when I'm...
Okay.
That's all right.
Here it will be fine.
Oh, my God.
These guys are actual meat shields.
I swear to God.
They're like bullet sponges.
Like, what is... What kind of bulletproof vest are they
wearing?
Okay.
There you go.
Come on.
Peek me.
Alright, it's okay.
You're not expecting this.
You're not expecting the most obvious plank ever.
That's alright.
I'm flanking.
I'm flanking in front of them.
Nice.
Last guy.
We did it.
Alright, what do we get?
Bandages?
Oh, man, I actually really need this.
I'm really messed up right now.
Oh, my God.
I forgot about my upgrades again.
Okay.
I got shields out of it.
Alright.
Hoop.
My five shields.
My five shields and a dream.
Ooh, snarf juice.
Actually, it doesn't really matter when you have, like,
five...
Alright, this is where things get tough, guys.
Remember, the boss here is a gamer.
Oh,
God.
Oh, God.
Don't let go!
Okay, he doesn't see me.
Okay, I got the rock.
Wait, I got my slurp juice.
I'm slurping.
Boom.
Well, that did nothing.
Like, with the charge up.
Okay, there you go.
Oh, shit.
Who's looking at me?
All right.
What?
Guys, I'm so safe.
I'm really safe right now.
Guys, guys, I am very safe.
Wait, we're missing one.
Where did our last guy go?
Guys, I'm very safe.
Oh, no.
We lost Hatsune Miku.
Not Hatsune Miku.
Wait, I have an idea.
Okay, watch this.
This AI doesn't know.
Oh my gosh, the AI is so confused.
There we go.
We did it.
Oh my, Hatune Miku down.
All right, dog.
Oh, I was gonna say, what?
Doggo?
Yay!
okay buddy all right we have our one rebirth we can progress
guys we made it oh and i got my life kit too we
made it to the next round some perished but we'll always
remember hatsune miku what
Well, at least me and Mordecai made it.
We made it, though, Mordecai.
We did it.
Okay, I gotta grab some H.
I gotta grab some shields.
That 5 was not it.
Let me get it.
Alright, more damage.
All damage.
We did it.
I think, Mordecai, it's just you and me, Mordecai.
We gotta go.
We gotta go live on.
We gotta progress in their memory, Mordecai.
Remember SMGs.
We will remember them.
Let's go.
You and I.
We can do this.
Surely it doesn't scale.
Okay.
Oh my god, we're...
your actual miners in mining in mining in mining there you
go
i'm not gonna say it i'm not what they're wearing mining
hats maybe it doesn't skill
what the fuck How did I just lose all my HP?
Like, what hit me?
What the
fuck hit me?
Who hit me?
Oh, no.
It's just you and I.
This?
Oh, my God.
It was this.
All right, let's go.
Oh, no.
Tight corridors.
It has a shotgun.
But he has no match.
Oh, my God.
I touched.
this I
oh we made it to a checkpoint oh my god yay we got the to be
fair I thought after I got down I was like invincible after
that yeah to be fair I I thought I I thought I was like
immortal.
I was like, surely it's not going to hurt me a second.
You know, like those moments where you're like, surely it's
not going to hurt me a second time.
But I think it hurt me a second time.
How is I supposed to know that?
All right, guys.
All right.
I am now going to do the second one.
I think I made it.
It's not, wait, did I make it?
Oh my God, I made it.
I made it.
I finished my job, but I have a second job to do.
Are you guys ready?
I'm going to enable it.
Wait, give me a second.
I got to make sure I changed the category.
All right, I got to change the category.
we got a job to do we did it guys we made it we did it never
punished we did it I also got to change the title to from
one ship to the other GG's guys change gotta go to my next
job GG
I'm gonna activate.
It was fun, though.
All right.
Job not done.
What the heck?
I changed it and everything.
All right.
Let's see if it works.
Why not activate?
Oh my god.
Do I have to give me a sec?
Maybe I can tell.
job done time for job two it's like the it's like that guy
in regular show wait not regular show it's like the guy in
gumball it's literally the guy in gumball he's like time
time to go to my next job and he has like 200 jobs oh yeah i
gotta change the sorry give me a sec twitch chat let me
where's the other twitch chat which twitch chat number there
we go that's the yeah i'm larry i'm literally larry right
now all right let me make sure i i
read every all of this i gotta read all of this so before we
go in booting it up
yo yo Yay!
Marble Rivals!
Yay!
Back to Marble Rivals!
But this time it's sponsored!
Let's go!
Alright, let me...
Boom!
Back to the Marble Rivals...
Marble Rivals minds.
Not only did I won money in the Bulgars, bash but i also am
gonna get paid additionally for playing rivals again i came
back you're right all right no we don't have to bully some
kids in game because i got third place in the end so all
right let me start it now all right this stream is sponsored
by marvel rivals Marvel Rivals Season 6 launches on January
16th, which is now, technically.
It's January 30th.
Deadpool joins Marvel Rivals on January 16th, and is free to
play.
You can check him out right now.
You can actually play Deadpool right now.
The game keeps leveling up with non-stop updates, new
heroes, new team ups, and new costumes.
Don't miss all the new content dropping on January 16th,
which is technically now.
Technically, two weeks ago.
Let's go.
So, yeah, you can play Deadpool right now for free.
Yes, that's right.
Marvel Rivals is a free-to-play game.
I can't believe...
I can't wait for January 16th.
Guys, you know what?
Just for fun.
Let us do go to Times Square.
To celebrate.
Guys, you know what?
Let's...
actually go celebrate in the only way I know how.
Yay!
Alright.
Celestia.
That.
Gold one.
this is the only way I know how to celebrate getting third
place oh my god wait where are the where are the people that
still have to go to school where are they oh my god where is
he when he walked by us guys he's captain of America.
You see a Captain America?
Guys, it was a captain.
Did anyone get the license plate on the Captain America?
Where is he?
Where did he go?
Oh my god.
Where is that specific Captain America?
He was right here.
God damn it.
I've run.
Cat run.
Oh my god, where are they?
Why are they all?
Oh wait, there he is again!
Where did he go?
Wait, where did he go?
He's right here somewhere.
Oh my god, he's running away.
He knows.
Captain America it keeps oh my god look at this little guy
though wait wow oh my god this is perfect no I disappeared
the little guy he do there he is escape I literally was like
oh my god there he is and I tap back in and he was god he
disappeared He actually just disappeared!
He's just a little cat.
Where did he go?
How did they know?
Okay, wait.
It was a tiny little man!
I lost him!
I lost.
Oh my god.
Look at how small you are.
You're so small that you don't even exist.
Wait.
One ton chopper.
God damn it.
There's no victims.
There's no victims here.
Wait.
You?
Oh man.
her tick.
Oh, wait.
She challenged Toe Tickler.
You're still worthy victim.
Oh, my God.
They're all grinders.
I need a new account.
Wait.
Alright, there you go.
Come on.
You know you want to accept it.
Wait, maybe All of these guys.
Oh, okay.
I challenge you.
Surely one of you guys would want to challenge me.
The Luna line.
The Luna Konga line.
Surely anyone in the Luna Konga line.
Too busy being Luna.
I'm a Tainan mutant.
Man, this is like the meeting of the Plats.
That's everyone.
All right, I'm going to take my risk on a private profile
I'm taking my risk.
Oh, my God.
No, don't accept it.
Don't Wait, I found him.
I I got impatient.
I actually I was like, wait a minute.
Okay, plat three.
Okay, this is doable.
This is doable.
Now you don't want them to accept.
Let him read his book.
I didn't think.
I was getting rejected all night.
How was I supposed to know he was finally going to accept
it?
Oh my god.
This is actually bad.
This is a bad matchup for me.
Because I don't get healed.
This is illegal.
Wait, wait, he's just healing!
Wait, it's not fair!
Wait!
Wait a minute!
What the fuck was- Oh my god.
Oh my god, he just kept- he just kept healing!
all right guys it's okay i got third place oh my god i'm
just gonna get healed diff i should have just played support
i should have just played support
there we go that's right cat out healed that cat out healed
this i'll heal this You know what?
Let's do it.
Let's do this.
When did we get out of Myvo?
This is my second job.
What?
Alright, I didn't expect Emma.
Oh, no.
This is actually very bad as Loki to play against Emma.
He...
Which one?
Which one is it?
Which lucky person?
Cross through the TP bit.
Just don't move that.
Yeah.
Lucky bird is.
real still a plat player after he's just like which one is
it all right let's queue up for an actual game now all right
here we go let's put our game face on we put our game face
on we're locked in
I'm so it's mine couldn't process what just happened it's
okay me too honestly Emma's actually really good against
Loki only for the fact that like she can build off her
charge off of my clones that's why I was like oh no I was
freaking out I was like oh no what is she gonna do
Oh, while we wait, you know what that means?
Since we're waiting.
Wait, maybe I should try that strat more.
I'm going to try that strat more.
That's actually pretty smart.
Apparently, apparently, there's already drama tweets about
the Terra versus Kingsman.
I think that's crazy like no he closed doors he knew he knew
yeah I saw a tweet that had like a 1k likes just now he knew
he took it away from me wouldn't see boy I want to see if we
actually I want to see if it works.
That was pretty funny.
Not gonna lie.
No!
Wait, Melina.
Melina.
Wait.
Okay, I thought it was this Melania.
I was like, wait, aren't you supposed to...
I was gonna say, aren't you supposed to be in that
tournament?
Or was did he got knockout?
I don't remember.
Don't worry.
Triple support is the way to go.
Because we have no tank players.
Who am I gonna from this match.
Don't worry.
Oops, all support players.
Love to see it.
Yay.
Oops, triple support.
Good.
I'm ready.
Yeah.
You know what?
I'm going to reward myself with...
Oh, a cough drop.
It's never too late to have triple.
Don't worry.
It's never too late for triple DPS to come in.
We just gotta wait for number three.
Number three.
What do you want?
Five.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the...
I want a tank for five.
How many hatches in?
Yeah.
What?
This is in rake now?
Oh no.
Wait, do you want to play mag?
Oh no, where am I?
Where am I?
It's the new map.
What do you mean a new map is in rake now?
What?
Where do I go?
Where is the- oh, it's over here.
Why is it so orange?
Where do they show up?
Like, where do I position myself?
I am just confused.
Oh my god, you're fine.
You're so healthy.
What's hitting me?
I knew it.
What the fuck is hitting me right now?
I'm jumping in the back on you.
Oh shit.
Wait, they're running triple.
Wait, why do they get to run triple?
That's not fair.
I want to run triple.
bro i hate this point i'm just i'm just so confused there
you go like i'm so confused right now
it's such a weird ass map in general yeah oh goodbye he did
he might be dead guys maybe just a maybe oh not living that
i thought i was gonna get to the counter gambit up there i
can kill him that was crazy
Alright.
I got my invis.
Okay.
Guys, I have been playing rocket and cloak the whole day.
The last two days.
Please understand.
There you go.
It's been pretty rough.
Yeah
Don't mess with the amazing spider that's awkward that's
That's very awkward
Holy shit there was no saving you there truly was no saving
you I'm just gonna melt
You have triple support
They do have it
Okay, I pushed them a little bit back Oh shit, nice, let's
go Oh, let's let's leave Shit Damn, let's just run it There
you go, we're fine, right?
We're so healthy no i'm sorry i can't do that oh are we not
oh we're we're just backing up that's that's cool that's i
thought we would commit to that but i guess not
oh he's diamond i didn't even see that guys i hate what is
going on with this map
Why did we ban, why did we not ban Gambit?
Oh my god, oh wait, we...
Awesome, why does Gold...
Where is this map heading?
That's another...
Man, if only we ban Gambit.
oh it's okay i'll die on card for us i don't think that's
the place oh my god we actually have triple support now oh
my god oh my god we're actually doing it it's okay oh my god
it's a full area too guys i think i don't like this map i
mean maybe it's Because, like, it's new?
But as of right now, this map fucking sucks.
Like, I don't know where to fucking position myself right
now.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
There we go.
He lives that.
I don't even know where he dashed.
Wait up.
Fuck, did he?
He is mad at that.
Let's keep fighting.
Let's keep fighting!
We can still fight here!
Come on guys!
First!
It's over now.
It's actually over now.
Never mind.
The fight has ended.
Surprisingly, the fight has ended.
Can't pull me when I have a dope.
Well, he didn't pull me though.
Just remember that.
He didn't really pull me.
We are undefeatable.
Alright, we got a pocket.
This guy.
Make sure he's okay.
They just don't take damage.
This is crazy.
Oh my god, it's too late.
I got Gryfft.
Yeah, and then we're going same combo with that in our body.
To be fair, they...
They have the thing.
We don't.
That hit me.
Oh my god.
Moxie!
Thanks for the- Is the tournament over?
I saw you were in watch, bro.
fighting
Top three we did it moxie Top yeah, but yeah, they were like
yeah this This team wasn't supposed was like in the worst of
the bracket and now look at you and I was like you didn't
have to say that To be fair that that's supposed to be an
inside thought not an outside thought Like but thank you for
the red moxie Thank you Yeah, I went back to Rivals because
I forgot I had, you know, like those The little bounty, the
moxie dokey, trust me, Kurt, trust me one, trust me one,
didn't trust me one Bougar Bash one.
Okay, that's my fault.
Bougar Bash one without us.
You played too deep.
You played here like in front of the...
And shut up, Rita.
I was not in this spot.
I got pulled in by the Spider-Man, but okay.
Oh, okay.
Oh, shit, Rita.
No, I don't play Gambit.
Our Gambit players take an M on.
I'll play Gambit.
Okay, I'm gonna get rid of that.
Back to your M on.
The battle starts in five.
Don't talk to me, I'm dead.
Oh, dude, he's so...
Oh, it's a little school, but...
I didn't notice that, but it was like getting my shit kicked
in.
Oh, I missed a plug.
Oh my god, save me!
I will have...
What the...
Guys, there is a lot of stuff going on.
oh my god what is going on okay i don't even know who to me
i don't know who to even avoid maybe i should just cue that
i pulled it i did my job i think i think oh my god please
there we go where is he no this is i don't even want to be
here anymore oh my god he was jumping up my head i fight for
my family until the end guys maybe we should just surrender
maybe you know maybe we can you know you want to be great we
could just surrender
We could all save time, guys.
It's okay.
Yeah!
I made it.
I hesitated, thank God.
Oh my God.
Please.
Like, I don't know if I should use it again.
Yeah, I don't know.
I like where do I alt that Where do I Where do I even Guys
please can we push our little Let us push our little bus a
little bit further It'll be pretty cool It'll be pretty neat
They let us push our little bus a little bit more Oh my god
It's okay It's no longer okay I don't want to die I want to
keep my KDA well my kitty is not that impressive right now
you died in all right goodbye no i agree you know i'm gonna
go back to what we were running yeah come on one more come
on one more yeah these kids are gonna be late for school let
us please let us take the kids to school I think
like half of this team was OCE
I'm pretty sure Oh my god what's OCE Oceanic Australia slash
New Zealand Yeah I think I think these I think, yeah.
Why did I play it?
And they, because OCE is dead!
They're never gonna get a game.
They're never gonna get a game in OCE servers.
That's so hot.
As I heard an accent on all three players that were yelling
at each other.
All three players that were yelling each other had accents.
And I was like, well, they all know each other.
I wonder why.
I was just like, well, all three of them seem to know each
other, and they all seem to really hate each other.
They have to QNA so they can get gains.
I'm gonna Q dodge real quick.
I'm gonna Q dodge.
I don't think I want to be in that game.
I don't think I want to be in that system.
Let's check.
Have they won?
Wait, who won?
Did they win yet?
Who won?
I'm just gonna wait.
I don't want to be in this system.
J3's team won?
You know what?
We lost to the champions.
That means, guys, we lost.
We lost to the team that won.
So technically, you might say that that's second place.
Basically, that might as well...
Yeah, that's basically second place if you think about it.
Exactly.
Technically second.
We lost the champion team.
It's because they banned Spider-Man.
Oh, did they ban Spider-Man first instead of Gambit first?
what it is.
Because I'm like, how did they get out of it?
So they let Gambit in?
Yeah, but was Gambit bad?
Gambit was played with Loki.
Oh, that's interesting.
Technically second.
I will...
I take this.
We lost to the champion, so technically second.
No, I'm Q dodging the full roster.
I'm Q dodging the full.
Question.
How to remove the collab ads on mobile Twitch?
20 more minutes.
Wrong.
Don't worry.
Time.
That's how.
Good question.
God.
Just 20 more minutes.
Alright, I'll just, I'll do one more duel.
And it made me.
I want to try out the duel.
I want to try out the low-key strat.
See if it works again.
What's, where are you?
Where is he?
It was literally the first guy I saw in the name.
Oh my god, he disappeared.
You saw me hover it.
That's real.
I feel like there's a lot more console players than I
thought.
I thought the main...
I literally thought the main, like, player base was PC.
But there is, like, a lot more...
I feel like in the Clobbering Club, it's just all console
players.
I like to hang out here.
It's pretty fun.
Wait, Roachy.
Man, where are the...
I'm hearing like Deadpool's conversation on the side.
Wow!
Okay.
Where is he?
Draw.
Where are you?
You know what, I won't fight this tiny shark.
I'm gonna fight you tiny shark.
I don't like the way you look at me.
And you're so tiny.
Fartmaster MVP.
I just noticed his name.
Fart.
All right.
I don't like the way you look at me, Tiny Shark.
Oh, yeah.
All right.
Let's try out the strat.
Let's try out the Loki strat.
Let's see if it works.
Let's see.
what a name tiny little man
which one is it which look is it
oh whoa you found figured it out you figured it out
that's right you don't have anymore
don't you don't have no more you got confused you don't know
the basic loki strat 101 you got pretend all right let's try
let's do the jet thing that's right tiny shark the mind
games oh shit i forgot about gamut oh shit
That is not fair.
He has self-heal.
He is self-heal for this.
Not fair.
So can I.
Not the only one with self-heal.
Whoa!
Yes!
The better Tani Shark!
That's right.
Tani Shark wins.
Let's go.
But she's cheating.
Hey, she...
Hey, he chose Gambit.
He chose Gambit.
That's on him.
That's right.
Tiny Shark wins.
Alright.
Does everyone have a game now?
Let's go.
Wait.
Well, was it Cooper on J3's team?
Bro, he won the tournament and he's like, I'm going back in.
It was six hours.
It was like eight hours of...
Look, for me, for me, it was a sponsor.
Bro, the grind never ends.
Bro, this guy literally won Bougar Bash.
And he went fucking back the grinding rink.
The grind never stops.
Bro, you won 3K.
you can rest now you can rest it's okay thank god i respect
i have had some respect right there never back down never
what bro if i won that tournament i'm out i'd be like peace
i ego stroke myself on twitter and then and then i had to i
get dinner and i had to bed top bro this guy's already top
500 he's already white above all that's not yeah toky that's
not win winner mentality you're right you're right we're not
the same we're not the same you know that's why i'm third
and he's first guys
That's the difference between me and him.
Bro, he's got to get rank.
Wait, is he number two right now?
Bro, he won Bougar Bash and he has to get rank one, too.
He's like, job ain't done.
Job not done.
Number one in the leaderboard and number one in Bougar Bash.
Yeah, win and rank one.
on the same day that's some fucking adrenaline that's that's
some dopamine rush right there rocket if i'm solo healing
i'm playing rocket fuck that we should get rank one whenever
whenever my career dies i'll do it whenever my i fully fall
off you'll see me there
Stop!
I'm nothing to lose.
Doki, no!
All right.
Go to the bends.
Did it?
Am I solo healing?
You'll need a top notch team to win.
Solo healing.
Well, looks like I'm 310.
Oh, my God.
Guys, come on.
Guys, come on, guys.
We all know this is silly.
Buy our merch, guys.
The store's closed right now.
Can't even buy my merch even if you want to.
All right, here we go.
Know what?
You know what?
In celebration of third place...
I'm...
Gonna remove Rocket from the whitelist.
That's right, today is a...
Today is a special day.
Okay, maybe not now.
I don't know how to do it.
Never mind.
Not right now.
I forgot how to do it.
I was the only... Alright, not...
Oh.
Oh, see?
This guy didn't even do it right.
Oh, no, not Spider-Man.
Luna, bro, Invis is open.
Oh, that's sad.
I saw what happened.
Well, I got you.
Guys, I don't think we're winning this.
Guys, it does...
It might look like we might be GG's on...
It might be GG's on Hero Select.
It might actually be GG's on Hero Select, guys.
Literally, the game started and then hella fucking jumped
off the cliff.
Accidentally, but still, that does not look so good.
concept wise that's your brain switched on what am i
watching
holy that's my marvel rivals guys marvel rivals is free to
play right down check out the sponsor
God!
And you too can enjoy the fun games I'm experiencing.
Let's go!
Let's not go!
Hey, so my thing is gone already.
I can maybe one shot called out.
Alright.
She's gonna hold in like two seconds probably.
Oh, she's dead.
Rocket dead?
I think she altered.
I love my brothers.
I don't know.
Alright, here we go guys.
We're doing it.
Wait, they don't...
Oh.
I don't think he hit that shit, guys.
Yay!
Guys, I don't think she she got the freeze.
That was awkward.
That was pretty awkward.
Not gonna lie.
Oh, oh, there's a Hawkeye.
And the temp was me.
Let's get out of the ring, guys.
Surely he doesn't know I'm right here, right?
That's fine.
Here you go.
I'm doing my job.
See, the Hawkeye doesn't know.
He's so stupid.
Look at him.
Oh, my God.
That's... Oh, my God.
I think he knew.
I...
I think he started to know.
Don't worry.
right here look at that look at that that namor does not
give a that he's getting beat up by a fast woman that's fine
okay I won the movie all right my god you're out here with
the squids watch this boom okay I think they might be able
to see that but that's okay oh my god that is so
embarrassing that
caught live on camera caught live too i had front roast oh
it's all right you did hit a headshot
oh i got the rocket No, maybe I should, like...
How is he still alive?
Oh.
Let's do it!
She should live.
Yeah, she should live.
Oh, that...
That is...
Oh my god.
my guy right after this tournament all the things i'm seeing
today it's a whole it's a whole nother fucking environment
what what am i looking at what am i looking at from this
game oh my god i feel like we can kill her right yeah what
the fuck out of game is this.
It feels like yeah, it does.
It feels like a fucking totally different game right now.
It really does.
It feels like these people, both my team doesn't have hands.
From the highs of pros to seeing.
The thing is, Celestial 1 is top 500 right now.
And I'm Celestial 2, Celestial 1 game.
So like, that's a little embarrassing
The fact that Celestia 1 is top 500 and I'm in a Celestia 1
to Celestia 2 lobby.
It's a little...
That's crazy.
Little...
Yeah.
Little.
weird now I know why pro players occupy 200 slots in top 500
now I know that's how you know the power creep the bottom
top 500 is like this and then like the gap between bottom
500 to pro top 500 or the bottom top 500 from the highest
levels of deboker bash to literally to literally a top five
like not top 500 i mean this celeste 2 celeste 1 so
technically no i've just been playing i just somehow got
into this elo like i said i just play it on and uh i don't
play it every day I just play like whenever I tournament
practice or like sponsors, I play it like literally right
now Hey guys, will you guys be okay?
I don't know if these guys would be okay.
They don't see me, right?
They don't know I'm here.
Well, my team's dead.
They don't know I'm right.
They don't they don't they know They don't!
They don't!
Why did you bring them in here!
They don't know,
right?
They don't know.
Oh shit!
We don't work!
I'm here.
I thought, to be fair, I just think, I thought most of my
teammates were alive.
They found us.
I thought I had my rest of my teammates alive there.
And I was like, oh, wait, am I the only one left?
Oh, that's awkward.
That was, that's pretty awkward.
I thought, I thought I had two more with me.
You know?
Yes, I might have saw them, but I legitimately thought there
were still two more.
Oh, no.
Aluna did.
Aluna's back.
Like, in my head, I thought there was still two more.
Oh, shit.
Respect the hot guy.
What the?
What?
Like, I'll just stay here.
Like, what the fuck is this cloak gonna do?
chasing me you freaking freak there you go you should be
okay now buddy you should be okay now still you should still
be okay oh my god i can't help you no more i can't i gotta
get closer to her okay all right there we go Oh, they did
push up a lot though.
Oh my god.
I saw her.
He looked at me And he stared at me.
Oh my god.
Whoa!
Oh, he broke the wall!
What?
Yeah!
Climb if there's no more walls.
Sir?
Am I good, sir?
Alex, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
I was like, where do I go in the wall?
Oh.
You're welcome.
Oh, that's awkward.
Not... Oh, wait, he got res.
Nice.
I'm gonna do it.
Watch this.
No!
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
It's worked.
It worked.
See?
All according to plan.
There you go.
See, I told you.
Did you watch it?
Did you watch it, guys?
It worked out.
I was not I was not fucking scared at all
Oh shit sorry I was too busy climbing
I'm gonna put it yeah I mean we do have Well I'm gonna oh my
god you fucking crazy bitch that's right my friends is still
here yeah oh my god wait that guy got deleted wait a fuck
wait that guy actually got deleted he he literally had all
there oh shit don't do not shoot me oh my god look at the
tanks look at the tanks wait what the What is wrong with
you?
What is wrong with you?
What the- what is wrong with that hook?
Don't worry, simple geometry right here.
Her hook is a goddamn freak.
I know who to avoid.
Oh.
you're not diffing me little bro oh my god oh no okay no all
right it's fine oh i hear him i hear him it's fine they're
so healthy see oh my god my walls my wall don't worry go go
go i put it in the open i should stop doing that i should
really stop doing that it might not be this it might not be
the smartest thing i'm not really say thank you for the
super chat thing it's like a flash grenade
You're like, flash grenade!
Y'all can actually go.
Look here.
Put it.
Let's go.
You don't have nothing to kill me yet.
Bro, I'm not.
I'm not focused.
I was just like, let's rip it.
Let's like be rip it.
It'll be so funny.
Okay, that's an interesting ult though.
That really is.
I don't like that.
we're stacking up against the moon night but that's okay
there we go it's working
oh my god oh i want her ass i don't know i don't know whoa
okay guys you know what can happen in that that's where
that's where moon night yep Hey guys, hey guys.
I don't know.
My god, it's the same response.
There you go.
I'm just like, that's...
Say it, Mario!
Please, the orb is literally here!
Angela, Angela.
Oh my god, I just hear her flying.
Don't worry.
Boom!
Oh, well, that's awkward.
But it's okay.
That's a little awkward.
Ooh.
You know, I got that, though.
Oh, hey, it still works.
Let's go.
Never punished.
Yay!
planned exactly say thank you about twitch prime thank you
thank you never punished
i was gonna say oh no 10 year old spider-man one trick on my
team who we didn't even ban spider-man Oh, this guy where he
played Spider-Man for like 10 You guys are triumphant not
going through either I was like, when did they have a
Spider-Man?
A guy went Hulk, Venom, Spidey, Deadpool, and Hela Bro
playing Mystery Heroes How the fuck was I supposed to know
which one was Spidey, man?
Like, like 30 seconds.
Spider-Man player.
Goddamn Spider-Man players griefing my games.
Those menaces of society.
They truly are.
What I feel like, I don't know.
That game was fucking weird.
Oh yeah, look at my...
Okay, not that.
That was when it started getting late.
But other than that, it was pretty clean.
It was pretty clean before it did.
This was clean.
This was pretty clean.
All solo queue.
And then, like, it got too late.
The time, it got a little too late.
And I got tired.
I got EP.
It was pretty clean.
And then I got EP.
See, Celestial Water's top 500.
It's crazy.
It's crazy that...
That's crazy that the gap.
Oh, yeah, I forgot.
The gap between players is absolutely insane.
All right.
I don't know.
Who sucked?
I guess I guess I will avoid them.
Melee only.
I mean, their DPS did work.
They did do work.
I gotta get water I'll be right back guys
Alright time to go to my favorite place I'm back by the way
Not sure Oh my god I thought that was the rank thing Alright
Oh my god No I don't have that I have this though here God's
business shark here yeah not the shark I have this dog do
not do not thank the shark yeah I don't know
Wait, let me challenge one of the sharks.
Let me challenge one of the sharks.
Which of the sharks wants to fight me?
Oh my god, that's a big-ass shark.
What's your name?
Big guy?
Dichala.
Alright, Dichala.
Let's fight.
Me and...
Oh, never mind.
Chala does not want to Does not want to fight To not the
shark
Oh hey Which hero do you think you want to be today?
How do you get to the clobbering club?
You go to the disco and then you go out
I don't After the tournament I'm here to relax That's right
it's relaxing time
how much time left oh my god we did it banners off yeah the
banners off that means it's done we did it guys we made it
thank you OMG and I'd be like alright guys that was this is
gonna be the last game we're not doing the third one no this
one I still have time Five more days.
I still, I still have five more days.
That means I'll see you in five days.
Take your hero.
I'm not judging.
Emergency stream on Wednesday.
Guys, I'm tired.
I'm so tired.
I did a seven hours tournament guys
yeah but we have one more game one more game we that's pot
Dustin stream on the anniversary let's go powers of stealth
would make you excellent assassins even told all right
Yeah All right, here we go The battle starts in five four
three
to do is capture the mission area got it Let's do this I
broke the res If they don't have a mag I'll go cloak because
we learned Oh shit.
Yo, Res beacon.
Yo, place your Res beacon, bro.
You need that for the fight.
Yo, your Res beacon still not down.
Our select's gonna die.
Nice.
You got it down.
Oh my god.
No, I heard stinkers.
He's a teenager.
So that's why he's like that.
Oh, goodbye.
Wait, they're running Adams, Jeff?
Yeah, that guy disappeared.
He really did.
Emma walked at us, so I'm gonna probably just get off
Naeemore here and go kill their Adam
Oh, God Why lag off the map?
It's not real.
Oh Okay Okay, guys, this might be you know what what a good
game to end this off
No Oh my god.
Oh, yeah, we did it.
Hey, there's a Jeff here that wants to kill my shield.
Alright, let's see if we'll double support or not.
That's my favorite part.
And then if I double support, let's see if they'll yell at
me.
Who will they?
going right again oh my god i didn't see that that was my
bad what the fuck holy what kind of angle was that that's a
crazy ass angle that was lush that's a crazy ass i will say
that angle is insane
the angle is insane i was not expecting oh my god he's gonna
do it again he's gonna do that again totally that was a sick
angle though that really is oh my god should be 18 under it
oh my god does he get res though he gets res though he gets
res though oh I'm gonna run now Hello I'm safe.
What the fuck?
Did he actually bro the Emma actually followed me all the
way back there.
That's insane No link I was I was like the only one in that
corner and I did not expect the Emma to show up Like next to
me That's insane I was not.
Oh my god.
I don't think he got anybody in general.
Oh, he got it.
Oh my god, he followed me.
He followed me.
Oh my god, the control also lost.
Yeah, I was like, where did he come from?
I mean, they don't have a club they don't have a mag so like
technically i couldn't i'm touching this what the what how
did he
how did they who was who shot my res bro bro bro like
oh well
all right wait where's my in oh wait i didn't realize i was
like i thought i got healed so i was like oh i'm fine my
name is this is next to me all right i'm coming back
i'm coming back guys i'm so tired but i'm coming oh they
used born again let's go
It is worth it to own me.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Let's go.
You know, I'm tempted.
I like going...
I've been thinking...
I'm sorry, I had a Jeff, AFK, and spawn before spawn doors
open.
Guys, this is why I put on streamer mode.
So I let them say their shit.
streamer modes and then they apologize it's cool
this is why i use streamer mode because i love it when that
happens
you can't blame
Oh shit!
Because he was the one that was like, you know you can, you
know you can put your thing down, right?
Because he's super fast.
And I was like, I heard he's a teenager, so like, that's why
he says shit like that.
Going back with hello.
You guys, this is the reason why Ghost Tree for more just to
see the back settle.
It works every time.
When I see like someone, like, because they're a pro player,
when I see like a pro player does that, I'll be like, I...
But it only happens when I stream.
The only worst part is that when I'm streaming, they
apologize.
Character development.
That's why whenever I get flamed by, like, a pro, I go live
afterwards.
Turn, move, move.
Are you fucking against?
I can't No, I don't turn off No, I did turn off streamer
mode I meant like After I got No, it's like My streamer mode
It goes My streamer mode goes off After a couple Like after
a couple of minutes Because it's like The streamer mode only
hides For like hero select In the first two minutes of the
game And then after that My name gets revealed And then
usually people backpedal Yeah, I- they- it's the back pedal
after that.
That's why I'm- I love it when it happens.
I- I fucking love it when that happens.
Oh, we should live, right?
You're fine.
There you go.
This guy's still chasing me?
Jeff-all, Jeff-all, watch out for it.
Oh.
What is he aiming at?
Oh my god, oh I lived.
Oh it didn't matter.
Alice, thank you for the raid.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, I'll go.
I'll go cloak now.
I think we need it.
Thank you for the raid.
Oh, that's unlucky.
Oh yeah, a good streak.
I love it when that happens though it's clicking is so funny
just hold me up I'll make up there I think it's so fucking
funny I should get fucking captured yeah both healers turn
and they more
all right we live we did it we did it we stacked
What the fuck get away from me?
All right, let's go!
You think I got this?
I'll get you next time.
There we go.
Let me go first.
All right, here we go.
Actually, Cloak ult, you go first.
But otherwise, let me just...
Let me do it.
All right.
They're not getting healed.
Oh, they Cloak ult.
They Cloak ult.
Double, double.
That pool is behind those.
I need a Cloak ult.
All right, here we go.
Boom!
Cloak ult!
What the fuck?
Oh, that's sad.
It's fine.
We have this.
Don't worry, I got you.
Don't worry, I still got you.
Okay, bro.
Okay, you gotta get me too.
Yeah.
I got...
Yeah!
We did it.
Still fucking hilarious.
Telling to you not, of course.
for the...
I'm sorry, I had a Jeff MMK spot before Star Wars open.
You can flame me.
Shit is fucking funny.
This is why I turned on streamer mode.
This is exactly why I turned on streamer mode.
They're not streamers.
I look.
I think it's fucking hilarious.
The reveal is always worth it.
It really is.
What if you get top five?
Nah.
Dude, that's too much work.
I don't got time for that.
Next week is my anniversary, guys.
My anniversary stream is nearly...
Nearly...
next week on the 7th.
What if, stop?
Wait, that's true.
Let's check.
Let's check if Cooper did it.
Let's check if he did it.
Let's see.
Did he make it?
Oh my god, he actually did it.
First place end rank.
What?
That guy was like, this is not enough what the madman that
guy was like first place is not enough I need more I need
this green nose no pounds like that's like crazy he actually
he actually got he actually Got it.
He was fucking locked.
I just agreed they talk about in the Bible.
That shit's crazy.
Hollow, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
All right.
I think.
I think this is a good time to call it.
Me tired.
I think I played eight hours.
Seven.
eight hours of rivals eight or nine i don't i lost count
it's time to rest no stream tomorrow me prep for anniversary
i'm like temp oh man no i won't tease you guys on what the
anniversary i was gonna be like should i should i like show
the teaser now but i'm like no i'll make you guys wait i'll
show it up i'll No, I gotta save it, because I know if I
show it, you guys are gonna, uh, you guys are gonna take,
clip it, or, like, screenshot it, and then post it on
Twitter, and then, like, I'll be like, no, my engagement
farm!
How would I pay for my Twitter blue now?
How?
My engagement farm!
Anyway, guys.
Hey guys, thanks for thanks for hanging out with me the
whole day.
I had I honestly, I thought I was gonna be knocked out on
the first round Honestly, I was like maybe not last is my
goal and like we got third.
I'm so happy I don't know about my teammates, but I'm happy
Like literally after the game everyone was so I keep
depressed.
I was like third place.
Yay Bro, I literally had boker and like who suddenly got
cloaks like Kloekski, right?
They're like from the bottom of the seed and yet now you're
here like from the one of the worst teams slash bottom of
the seeds like now you're here and I was just like what?
You don't have to say that part out loud?
You know?
From the lowest of the low the worst team in the entire
tournament and apparently Their captains were like, this
team is bad because they picked and drafted wrong.
I was like, I did it.
I got three.
They had to call us ass.
Yeah, now we're third.
Yay.
Yeah.
And now look at us.
That's right, Necrofts!
That's right!
I heard what you said.
I almost thought you were right.
But look at me now!
I played four plus hours of Rockin' and Cloak last night.
And it worked.
It worked.
And who's wrong now?
You almost got me there.
You almost got me there I thought you were right But now I'm
third We did it Prove them wrong Yeah Hey guys Thanks for
all the support From today's tournament And today During my
scramble And trying to get the sponsor stuff done Um Yeah
guess who's thirded Not last Ha ha ha Ha ha ha Hey, guys.
If you want to support me via other means, please check out
my YouTube channel.
This is where I mainly stream on YouTube.
So, check me out there.
It really does help out a lot because I'm trying to aim for
a million subscribers.
And I would like your subscription, please.
If you want to know whenever I stream on Twitter.
Sorry.
My throat ain't good right now.
But.
You want to follow me, follow me, and figure out whenever I
stream on Twitch, check me out on Twitter.
Because that's where I tweet out whenever I stream on the
Twitch.
And I guess that's it.
There's no merch store right now.
So check that out next week, I guess.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Oh, yeah, thank you for all the subs, the bitties, the
follows.
I really appreciate it.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
You stay up from me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.